[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe this time I'll be lucky maybe this
time he'll stir
[Music]
maybe this time for the first time love
won't hurry I'll be home at last not a
loser anymore like the last time and the
time before everybody
love so win her
so nobody loved me
I call singing my first language our
currency is being open and being opened
and available to our emotions if you're
closed off as a person how are you gonna
be a performer to get out there and you
know show love or show agony or show
despair listen make sure I'm listening
to the person I up I'm up there on stage
with because if you're truly listening
then that'll force you to be in the
moment yes the strong get some more
while weak once pain empty pockets don't
ever make the grade
[Music]
he'll probably hell but god bless the
child less got his own yes God is Oh
[Music]
evolution is very important to me as an
artist usually if I'm scared of it I
know I have to do it I will be a better
actress a better artist doesn't
necessarily mean that I will succeed but
will I have grown as a result
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
good afternoon I'm Philip quarry and it
is my great pleasure to welcome all of
you to the 2018 Eugene McDermott award
in the arts celebration celebration of
the extraordinary Audra McDonald and if
any of you were at Symphony Hall last
night and had the privilege of listening
seeing and listening to Audra McDonald
you'll know just how extraordinary she
is first I want to recognize Mary
McDermott cook who is with us this
evening Mary McDermott cook is the
president of Eugene McDermott Foundation
she has been an inspiration to all of us
at MIT for her great support and in
support of her remarkable mother
Margaret McDermott Margaret McDermott is
the individual who created this award 44
years ago and it has been a thriving
award throughout and Margaret couldn't
be with us but Mary is always with us
here representing her mother and also
here with members of friends and members
of the McDermott family so we're just
delighted Mary for your tremendous
support and we wish Margaret were here
with us and you I know you'll wish her
all of us the best for her
now as associate provost with
responsibility for the Arts at MIT I'm
reminded every day of the importance the
arts are to the pursuit of excellence at
this great institution of ours our
unparalleled public art collection is
one example but also the concerts the
plays the exhibitions the ins
installations put on by our Performing
and visual artists on our faculty and
among our students not just for this
but for the world our students who
mainly come here to study science and
engineering also partake and participate
in the arts fully nearly half of all
undergraduates at MIT for example choose
to take a class in the Performing Arts
each academic year that is one reason it
has felt so appropriate to have had
Audra McDonald in our midst and
especially for our vocal students to
have had the opportunity to perform and
be coached by her and she paid tribute
to them last night in remarkable ways
for which will never forget which will
never forget
now Audra McDonald is one of the most
accomplished actor singers of the
American Musical Theater of course MIT
is not the only one who has noticed her
over the years we're not the last but we
aren't the first you could call Audra a
serial award winner six Toni's two
Grammys an Emmy a National Medal for the
Arts from President Obama and much more
I should make clear that she has earned
the McDermott award not for a single
work or for lifetime achievement but for
certain qualities that reflect mi t--'s
values and ideals first her commitment
to risk-taking for embracing and
mastering the most challenging roles
especially as she said those roles that
scare her as one critic wrote she
immerses herself in roles with such
unrelenting fortitude that it simply
knocks you out a second quality is Audra
McDonald's versatility which reveals
equally well in performing musical
theater in the Great American Songbook
in Shakespeare and most recently in
network television and a third quality
is her ability to connect creative minds
across disc
something that we are totally committed
to at MIT as she commented upon
accepting our invitation to receive the
McDermott award my greatest hope is that
art helps us as a society to find common
ground to create dialogue and to
understand each other in new and
meaningful ways
now we're thrilled that Audra McDonald's
colleague and friend Oscar Eustace has
joined her today to speak with us he has
been artistic director of the Public
Theatre of New York since 2005 and is a
professor of dramatic dramatic arts
writing and public policy at New York
University the Public Theatre arguably
has done more to nurture America's best
writers and directors and actors than
any other institution as well as the
democratize theater by expanding the
roles participants and art forms
associated with it these days the
transformation can be summed up by
mentioning one show one word Hamilton
which premiered there at the Public
Theater in early 2015 but the innovation
and expansion of the Performing Arts
that have characterized Oscar useless
his leadership of the public theater
have been in progress for years now and
no doubt will continue to transform
theater in the United States and beyond
Audra McDonald appeared in the Public
Theater's 2004 production of Henry the
fourth and in 12 ninth Twelfth Night in
2009 and I'm certain Audra and Oscar
have much more than these productions in
common when it comes to their vision for
theater and for the contributions the
arts make to society I know they do
together Audra McDonald and Oskar Eustis
will discuss some of the highlights of
her career
how theatrical revivals reflect the
times and the evolution of social
attitudes and cultural experiences and
how theatre has evolved to become
more inclusive and more representative
of contemporary diversity please join me
in welcoming Audra McDonald and Oskar
uses
Aundre I think we should get the
formalities out of the way okay we're
talking today to the greatest singing
actress in the history of the American
and sorry but it's true and the thing
that we're gonna be exploring today is
we're gonna try to figure out a little
about how she does it so we can imitate
it yes so we can appreciate it a little
more and I'd love to start this is a
research institution and I'd love to
start with Lady Day okay because your
performance in Lady we play today was I
thought absolutely miraculous not only
the tremendous spiritual and emotional
depth
you brought but also the transformation
of your voice and the fit it was it was
uncanny deeply disturbing how did you
understand that about Billie Holiday um
well you know I I was always a terrible
student I was never good at doing my
homework on time and and doing it
thoroughly but I was always a good
student when it came to researching
roles and and and my work in the theatre
and with Billie Holiday I researched her
into oblivion I mean I I I not only read
every book I could about her I dug up
every audio interview I could find of
her speaking I mean she threw his
interview she did with Mike Wallace
there was certain other you know radio
programs in Amsterdam
and in Sweden as well as in the States
there's a lot of audio recordings from
rehearsal she had with her band when she
was just at one of Jim eros apartment
her where do you find those repeated all
over the place on the internet the dark
web a lot of places in you know and a
lot of books that I read would make
mention yeah you know where to find them
and and and those it was very
interesting with those particular
recordings especially the ones where she
was rehearsing with her band as you'd
hear the interviews of her with Mike
Wallace and then her very off guard with
her band and hear the the difference not
only in lucidity to be depending on how
drunk she was or you know wherever her
you know her mental state was but she
was also an incredible rock hunter she
was very funny when she would tell
stories she was very good at imitating
people as well so I did all of that
oral research of course all of her
recordings are her vocal recordings for
singing and then I interviewed everybody
I could find that was still alive that
knew her that spent time with her I
talked to dr. Maya Angelou who had spent
some time with her I spoke to some of
her old pianists I spent time with her
godson and you just asked them every
story everything and as the show was
running more and more people would come
to see the show that had spent time with
her so people would bring it people
would come backstage and bring me little
bits and pieces of her through stories
they had one woman whose father ran on a
dive nightclub somewhere and she was
charged with going to pick up Billie
Holiday and bring her to the club to do
the show and you know she told me the
story of how we had to stop and get a
big old bottle of I think it was gin and
she drank half of it by the time they
got to the club and it was only like a
20-minute Drive you know so people would
bring me bits and pieces of her and then
finding her actual voice I realized the
more I listened to the audio recordings
of her speaking the more I realized
she sounded and had a cadence quite a
bit like my grandmother my paternal
grandmother and as a child I used to I
mean and I did it even as an adult until
she passed away my mom's here my mom
would remember this I used to I used to
imitate my my grandmother and all of my
all of her daughter's my aunts to their
faces because I just thought it was
funny to imitate them and sometimes they
thought it was funny and sometimes they
would you know be quiet but I used to
imitate Nana all the time and I realized
one day and listening to Billie
Holiday's like she speaks like Nana Wow
oh my goodness
Billie Holiday's sounds like Nana so I
started imitating Nana and that's how I
found Billy that's how I found the vocal
quality for Billie a so I in some ways I
thank my grandmother because I use she
was my conduit to get to you know Billie
um but I have to ask in addition to your
grandmother and the research a so much
about Billie Holliday was affected by
her drug dependency and substance abuse
and how how and when I watched you on
stage it felt like I was watching
somebody who understood that really much
more deeply than your career could have
allowed you to understand that yeah so
well I mean I did the research I dodged
no no I did not actually do heroin
however I did the research I we talked
to heroin addicts survivors we talked to
I say we mean Lonny price my director
who sort of brought the project to me
and you know held my hand the whole way
through we looked at lots of footage of
people not only under the influence but
people who were who had been through it
and lived to tell the story we talked to
some methadone addicts and so we did all
that research I also
drank really heavily one night and tried
to do as much of the play as I could
just not not on stage but just at home
yeah I didn't get very far but I got the
feeling of what that was like to work
through and and and and try and function
through that fog yeah I talked to
doctors too
I'm just to get an idea of what the body
is going through what happens to the
body and also it's a very specific time
when the play takes place for months
before Billy Holladay passed away so she
was dealing with very specific medical
issues she was quite swollen her she was
not eating really at all her her legs
and her ankles were completely swollen
her stomach was very distended all of
that so I had all about as reference to
sort of you know so it's like putting on
you know big heavy sandbags and then
trying to walk through life okay you
know and walk through life so that gave
me that helped me with the physicality
and all of that I feel like makes sense
in terms of what I saw on your
performance what I also saw was an
emotional rawness that was breathtaking
it was it was it felt it made me feel so
self-conscious almost to be watching
somebody that how do you do that eight
times did you do at a temperature seven
I dated eight times a week in London I
only did it seven times a week on
Broadway
I did eight times a week in London and I
had a seven eight month old baby with me
so that that helped the whole fatigue
that was quite real but of course that's
characteristic that the emotional open
sometimes characteristic of your work
yeah and it is it is it's a thing yeah I
think you know it's interesting when
people out of stuff a lot of times you
know reporters will ask me or someone
who's interviewing will ask me you know
what what did you learn about Billie
Holiday
you didn't know that surprised you the
most and I think what surprised me the
most and this is gonna sound odd and I'm
and I'm realizing it as I'm saying it
well it surprised me the most
but maybe unlock the key to everything
else making sense about Billie Holiday
was how much she wanted children and how
much she wanted to be a mother more than
anything in the world she wanted that
she wanted family she didn't really have
it and she wanted it more than anything
she tried to adopt twice and was
obviously turned down was devastated by
that and so a lot of the sort of
loneliness and sadness that she felt
especially because I am a mother I do
have that joy and that blessing in my
life I was I was able to tap into what
life you know what that would be like
you know this woman wanted that so
desperately and didn't have it you know
and for some reason that just kind of
was the key into her the bottom of her
sadness for me guys she shrugs as if you
know what you've described is a level of
research into her and her medical
condition into the people who knew her
into the spiritual heart of her and into
your grandmother's voice all of which
you know and part of what strikes me is
what an enormous amount of work that is
that is not happening just in the
rehearsal hall it's happening as you're
creating the park yeah
yeah I mean that's that's that's the
life of an of an actor you know I was I
did an interview with one of the MIT
students a great girl who has spent a
bit of time within my residency here
named Thalia she has a little video
series called T with teachers and so we
were just recording that and we had some
tea and she had a little Reese's peanut
butter cups out there for me too which
made me very happy
but I was telling her that you know you
know being an artist especially when
you're being an actor and you have to
the research is just as intense as if
you were researching you know about nano
molecular our archaeological hoo-ha I've
looked into that food but it's you you
have to be that thorough with your
research I mean if you're gonna go out
there and be this person you have to you
know know everything that you possibly
can about them we are not gonna focus
solely on your drug-addicted character
you you rather famously your best both
the addiction felt realer than any best
that I had ever read about her seen
before but you are also struggling out
with a real person but with a fictional
character with a very you know
problematized history who she was can
you talking what is at one in the same
moment a classic and yet a very
pragmatic perspective on
african-american life and yeah one if
you could talk about what that was like
well you know in portraying Bess I you
know the important best was a musical or
opera depending on how you want to refer
to it and I know there's a debate about
that all the time about what it is that
I had loved deeply and was quite
obsessed with and knew from top to
bottom I could sing every single part in
my in my
and Juilliard and a lot of times I would
you know and I just sort of put on the
record the record yes it was a record at
that point and sing through the whole
thing and so when I was offered the part
I knew I wanted to not only you know
research the Opera and everything as
much as I possibly could but I wanted to
really make sure I understood the
genesis for who this this woman was and
so I went back to the book I went back
to the source material which is the book
by DuBose Heyward and I really studied
this character and there were certain
things in the book that obviously don't
that didn't make it into the libretto
which we're interesting to me the fact
that she had a huge scar on her face and
that's one of the first ways that DuBose
Heywood Haywood describes her she's this
you know statuesque woman you know buxom
woman a little bit past her prime
humongous scar on her face which told a
story I mean I think he even refers to
it in that way that there was a story
there you know and so I was trying to
just get right down to the bones and
then you know I did the research about
you know what it was like to be an
african-american woman at that time and
what your choices were your choices they
were very limited you know your choices
where you you had to be you know have
some sort of an income so either you
were working or you had a husband that
was supporting you I mean mom am I right
in those days I mean I knew not that you
were there in those days I'm just saying
no you're too young for that but you
know for african-american women during
this time you know there just weren't
many options so if you didn't have
either one of those things a lot of them
had to turn toward you know either
prostitution or men that would support
them in whatever way or whatever
contract that they can come up with and
I you know once again I studied the life
I went I went to catfish row in South
Carolina
I went to the cabin where
Gershwin wrote most of Porgy and Bess
and then obviously there was the
political ramifications you know of you
know we were doing it here in Cambridge
and the New York Times did the story and
then mr. Sondheim wrote a letter and you
know about you know not his son well I
mean it just in terms I mean and it's
because everybody's very passionate
about porgy and bess but there and I
think Gershwin absolutely approached
this with love and and with as much as
he could give to it as much as he could
possibly understand but he was still
writing about a culture that he may have
studied as much as he possibly could but
he couldn't there was a part of it that
wasn't his that he was not ever going to
get into and so for us it was very
important to make sure that we infused
it in a way that had I don't want to
choose the wrong word but the
understanding and the nobility and pride
of that people that perhaps there was no
possible way that Gershwin could have
put into those characters because he
that's not a culture he came from even
though I think he wrote them with love
so can you talk in just famously here in
Cambridge Bess rejects the drugs at the
end yes and then by the time you came to
New York you'd changed that decision yes
and I mean can you just talk a little
bit about that sorry if I um no no I
mean you know I think with with Diane
Paulus who was was a brilliant director
and in charge of the AR T Diane was
trying to we were you know we had been
given this sort of charge from the the
estate to you know alright to dust it
off see what you can find there and so I
think we were throwing everything at the
wall and seeing what worked and so Diane
wanted to try it this way and directors
who have worked with me have I think
lovingly and and and honestly said that
I'm I'm not maybe I am okay I guess I'm
difficult to work with
I would i will try something
I will intense endeavor demanding I will
try anything once
and I will try and if it doesn't if you
cannot convince me of an organic and
truthful why it's never gonna work on me
III won't be able to execute it I won't
be able to do it and as many times as I
tried to do it
rejecting the drugs in the end it it
wouldn't work she watched the show and
come back and go okay can you try you
know and I and it wasn't that I wouldn't
do it it's just that I couldn't find the
Y anywhere within my bones and I guess
that makes me a bit difficult to work
with no but and so in the end Diane and
I decided okay let's try it this way and
then we tried it that way it's like okay
there she is there you are and now
Audrey you're you're giving me it's it's
it's making sense and it's ringing true
organically for you in your performance
and it was it also I mean frankly in New
York it was heartbreaking it was
devastating and that very question that
you have had no bullying the character
weirdly enough she was more in noble
falling than she was resisting because
you could feel the size of the spirit it
was going under it was just
extraordinary it's interesting to to
have played those characters back to
back to play best and then to afraid
Billie Holiday James Baldwin wrote about
Billie Holiday's death right around the
time of her death you know hits seeing
her in that kiss yes and then you know
about seeing her in the hospital and he
said that she if if people would she
would die if people would only leave her
alone you know but he also said I am
told this is awful but he said I am told
that Dorothy Dandridge is an actress I
have yet to seek that be the case this
is what James Baldwin said because he
and a lot of people felt that Billie
Holiday should have played that part
that it should have been given to Billie
Holiday that she knew who best was she
understood that she understood
everything about what best was cuz
that's really astonishing and that best
should have played that role and James
Baldwin was a friend of best and
therefore that's why he was a bit
skating and saying that about Dorothy
Dandridge I mean the image of her
playing yeah um but speaking well you
had a lighter role in the show but
carousel which is coming back to us
and which was the the first time that I
and most of the world actually fully
realized how great you were is in that
production which was you were just
amazing it but carousels also
problematic I mean it's we had a little
celebration of you know wife-beating and
you know sometimes it doesn't feel like
yeah um so what does it feel like to and
he was coming back to overseas now to
you know it's interesting when we were
doing carousel back in 1994 one of the
nights that we were during the show was
the night of the infamous slow speed
white Broncos chase down the 405 with no
Jay Simpson on the run and it was so
interesting we were all just you know
our hackles were all up as we were
getting ready to start the show that
night because everybody was watching
what was happening is like places we got
to go and then to step into this world
you know or you've got this wife this
this you know domestic abuse situation
and it's interesting I think what I was
saying to Oscar an hour talking about
this a little bit backstage with that
show it doesn't just because the
character says something it doesn't
necessarily mean that it's true right
you know and so I think for some people
that are saying why are they doing
carousel again it's about a wife-beater
and then you know then she seems to
think it's fine and she says it's fine
how could you how could you know why are
we doing that in the age of me too and
how could you you do that this is you
know how certain people in this
particular situation are dealing with it
just because Julie says yes it's it's
possible for somebody to hit you
you're really hard and it not hurt at
all Julie can say that and not
necessarily mean it but realize she has
to say something to this child who's had
this emotional experience and when we
did carousel to watch Sally Murphy the
girl who played that part when she said
those words or even when she's saying
what's the use of wandering it wasn't
just yeah he beats me you like it's
really and it's really great and I love
him here is a high girl she she didn't
say it like that at all
she sang it from a place of anger at
herself she sang it from a place of just
being resigned that that's this is the
life that I have chosen and she sang it
from a place of and in the end
throughout all of it I still love this
man and I can't figure out why but I do
and that's real and that's real today
for women and certain people in 2018 and
so that's why I think carousel can still
have all the relevance that it needs to
have another you need to shy away from
it I mean you can shine a light on it
all but you can that once again will
show us like theatre is brilliant at
doing is how you know one you know one
person's experience what you describe
what's so interesting is that it's not
shying away from a try I'm trying to
polish up how ugly the motion is but it
is creating perspective it is saying we
don't have to simply buy this as God's
point of view no we see it in context
yes and then you can then sort of almost
you can really weep for that person
right all right god right one did you
could save yourself for that someone
could save you from that
you know it's ending that's exactly what
you're saying about best in porgy and
bess to which is that the way that you
alter it is not by making a happy ending
no is not by changing how dark it is but
by letting us understand how dark it is
exactly letting us understand from say
that's with how the Greeks got it right
with in terms of why we have theater in
the first place is because we needed to
see people up there you know you know
what killing their fathers having sex
with their mothers whatever you know
going through all these huge you know
emotional things
because it was it gave us more
understanding of ourselves and you know
gave us the catharsis that we needed
she's setting me up now I'm not a good
way and I go she being that no just
saying that Aristotle in a poetics he
has this famous statement that tragedy
shows people is better than they are and
comedy shows people is worse than they
are and the way I have always
interpreted that is not as say the
neoclassical French did that that meant
that tragedy had to be about nobility it
meant the tragedy was about people who
were more willing to follow through on
their desires and face the consequences
of their desires than we are and comedy
is about people who are more desperate
to avoid the consequences and we are and
I think you know this is exactly what
you're describing and for a bass and for
Julie and carousel um so Audra I promise
that we're going to at least try to
figure out a little bit of how you can
do this how did you start doing this
where did you I mean your mother's here
we could ask her but where did you where
did you come from
[Music]
and actually on behalf of the American
theater actually let me take this moment
to formally thank you for one of the
greatest gifts the American theatres
ever had we know there wouldn't exist
without you so thank you um but so how
did you start
what did how did they know you were an
actress Wow from age 2 on odd Rosen
actress think animated emotional about
little things I'm sure they didn't seem
little to audre yes deathly afraid of
thunder very I was very afraid of
thunder so how did you find the theatre
which Philip
to celebrate our wedding anniversary
at a local dinner theater and before the
actual presentation there was a group of
young people who did a cabaret show and
they called them the junior company and
after they performed and we had been
dealing but one of Audra's performances
at home at the time my husband was
taking some child psychology classes it
really was and he asked his professor he
said I've got this kid at home just I
mean it's like she's a parade every day
and he said you need to channel that
energy
well someone but we were told you might
want to put her on ritalin you know get
her into something like that because
they called her hyperactive and when we
were sitting and saw all of these kids
performing we looked at each other and
said truck let's get her up there and
that's what we decided to do we let her
audition and she became a part of the
junior company and had an outlet for all
of that energy
and did you know right away that this
was what you were gonna keep doing right
away so how old we yeah yeah yeah and
what did it feel like
I don't calm which is crazy no no no but
I felt I you know I it's exactly what my
mom described I had I had an outlet you
know I mean if I was gonna freak out
about the Thunder I could freak out
about the Thunder while singing onstage
I get paid $10 a week to do it which was
my was my salary at the time I was
thrilled with the $10 a week but yeah
and so for me I had an outlet so I I I
didn't I felt I felt normal
yeah I felt normal I didn't feel crazy
or I didn't for me for my memory is that
I didn't feel like I was a problem
anymore and that maybe and I'm sure
there were more problems to come but in
the sense that I had a place to go and
be myself you know and it just it was
like it just fit I just think it's like
that piece in a puzzle there's an
opening in the middle of a puzzle and
they just plugged me it's like okay
that's where okay that's why I have this
piece that looks like this and this
piece is my heart that beats really big
like that cuz it fits in here you know
so that's yeah that's you know what's
funny about that is that you're the
greatest performer of a generation and
I'm just a guy who runs a theater and
that's exactly how I felt about the
theater my there's I felt normal the
first time I didn't feel like I was too
loud for the first time I didn't feel
like I cried too easily yeah oh I didn't
feel like I laughed too much
all of this stuff that I was and I was
in Minnesota and boy Minnesota Fresno is
yeah yeah and the the crying too much
thing for not good but it's exactly you
feel you found your tribe found your
tribe and it lets you know it's the
beautiful thing about the theater is
that I've never found anything that I
care about that I can't bring into the
theater and he's subject I'm interested
in any feeling of heaven yeah there's a
place to it's a space yeah absolutely
and so when as you started growing up
and went off to that very non
competitive place Juilliard that very
sort of accepting it almost hippies
school how'd that work out what did it
feel cuz once you're there that's like
serious professional yes
I mean Juilliard was it seems like it
should have been just like right along
the the trajectory but for me you know I
I auditioned for a couple of different
schools and God I think got into UCLA
and UC Irvine and NYU and my mom took me
to New York to audition for Juilliard
and I I just blew the audition because I
didn't I didn't really know about opera
and I didn't think that that's where I
would end up but I just thought let me
audition for the vocal Department
because I think my singing is my strong
point
but I was thinking that I'd end up in
you know a musical theater department
there's no musical theater department a
Juilliard but I hadn't figured that part
out
so I went ahead and I auditioned and I
you know I rift at the end of baby any
known thought of God which is you know
Mozart's you know aria from you know
they don't say they figure oh you don't
riff
mozart but i did I I said I was a
mezzo-soprano even though I was singing
a soprano REI so yeah I'm a med so that
I say they're like no you're not what do
you mean I just was terrible and they
accepted me so it was like well
Juilliard accepted me I better say yes
especially before they figure out that
they made a mistake so I just I just
went and I just thought well I'm in New
York I'm close to Broadway I'm living my
address was on Broadway here we go this
is gonna happen and what I thought was
you know this trajectory felt like I've
because I was in the vocal performance
which which meant you study your
languages you study your Italian your
French your German your Spanish your
English diction you take literature
material classes you take your training
classes you take all the classical
classes you need to be a classical
musician you have your voice lessons and
that's it Wow and so all of a sudden I
felt like I have I made the wrong turn
somewhere and I am never gonna get to
Broadway a and B I hate what I sound
like I don't want to be an opera singer
I don't like singing like this that's
not what I want to do yeah what's
happening it was it was a very confusing
time for me Wow
but I ended up finding out that I did
have an operatic sound and Julliard
helped me discover a whole section of my
voice that I didn't know existed and so
once I was able to figure all that out
and then come back around the bend I
mean and maybe my path was this way and
I just thought it was this way I don't
know yeah or it's just life what's
happening to you and I was letting you
figure things out yeah and I was in the
exact right place but I passed her the
whole time I was there and you could
have never convinced me that I was yeah
I mean partly is that your mistake
started at the audition of thinking that
your voice was your strong suit I want
to point out that Audra is the only
actor in
American history who has won every
possible Tony Award for Best Supporting
Actress Best Best Lead Actress Best
Actress in a Musical and Best Supporting
Actress in a Musical I don't think your
voice is your only strong just the
jury's in on that but so so but but it
was right in the middle of there yet you
went to carousel right or right after I
had I had I had a breakdown well I was a
Juilliard I had you know I had a bit of
a mental break I had a suicide attempt I
ended up in a mental hospital for a
month and I took a semester and a little
more off from school and then I went
back just all supported by the school
they were very supportive and it's
nothing that I hide I talk about it
quite openly especially because I know a
lot of young people listened to me and
and and follow me and follow my career
and I want them to know that there's a
way through and so I went back and while
I was there I got the opportunity to
audition for carousel and no no no I got
the opportunity to audition for The
Secret Garden which was going on tour
and I auditioned and they accepted me
and I had to ask permission to leave
school to do it and they said yeah go do
that we think that's probably where
you're going to end up anyway so we're
fine with it so they let me go and they
said you can defer and just graduate
when you're done with that so I came
back graduated went back out on the road
with that and then auditioned for
carousel and got carousel so a year
after I graduated I open like almost two
months a year and two months after I
graduated I opened in carousel across
the street at the Vivian Beaumont and I
could literally from the Vivian Beaumont
look up and see my school and like some
of my classmates that have gone on to
get their master's degrees we're much
smarter than
so what not but just so it was it was
that's pretty magic it was pretty and
very lucky it did feel I mean there in
the Belmont during carousel did it feel
like you we're now on the path you
needed to be on did it feel right did it
feel yes as much as one can be present
at 23 yes
no no do you know in that sense that you
know life is still happening here and
you know I wasn't as fast ik 23 year old
but yes in that sense I felt like yes
I'm I'm doing I'm on Broadway but I'm
singing Rodgers and Hammerstein in a
pretty decent with a pretty decent
technique in a classical way that I
wouldn't have known how to do had I not
gone to Julliard you know um I just
wanna thank you for talking about
psychological difficulties um that's a
big deal odd right it's or something
that'll off a lot of people don't talk
about
and you know again it's just it's part
of the way you talk about it it's just
so clear that the difficulties you had
you have integrated recovered from and
built an absolutely not only
extraordinary career an extraordinary
life because I do know her a little bit
and I will say that Audra is proof of
one of those things that the really
greatest artists are the best people I
know there's some just below that level
who can be real jerks but but seriously
the really the the greatest artists I
know are just there they are that great
partly because of the size of their
heart and the integration of their
spirit and so thank you for that you
know maybe we could take just a minute
to talk about I know you're really
involved in Covenant House I know you
and you've you've become more of an
activist and I think that's due to well
a couple of things I I'm very aware of
how lucky I am and how and the
opportunities that I've been given and
and a great amount of luck and and and
blessings I've had in my life and you
know I have always been vocal that's a
good word to use about everything
thunderstorms yeah under storms whatnot
but I think activism really started you
know in earnest when I mean my I was
certainly raised you know in a very
democratic household and my and and I
know my mom's brother uncle Lloyd did
the sit-ins and stuff right that during
the sixties yeah because they went there
from the Washington DC and Virginia area
and so that was sort of in my blood and
on my dad's side of the family as well
my great-uncle was an activist he
actually worked with Bobby Kennedy for a
second met Bobby Kennedy I think was to
meet with him the day after he was
assassinated Uncle Jesse
at any rate all that to say that it's in
my blood and then I am met my my
wonderful husband will who's also here
and he's an actor and so we blended our
families and we're you know raising our
kids together and we'll was working with
you on hair will was starring in hair
and Oscar was producing that the public
and then on Broadway right in the midst
of the marriage equality movement and
Oscar and will and all the rest of wills
cast got very involved with that and I
it was it was certainly something that I
was very passionate about being someone
who absolutely believes in marriage
equality and LGBTQ rights and we got
very much not caught up but just very
involved with that movement and did the
March and then rallies in in in New York
City and I went up to Albany to you know
Lobby members of our Congress up there
and and then I was looking for a place
to donate money on opening night of Lady
Day instead of giving opening night
gifts to my cast I thought I cuz the
cast is consisted of me the band of the
the dog Chihuahua what do I get the
Chihuahua for opening night so we
decided to do I decided I would do a
donation somewhere and I thought about
the Covenant house which a lot of
Broadway folks had done some work for
the Covenant House is a shelter for
homeless youth and there was homes in
Canada and in the United States and in
Latin America as well and so I went down
to do a donation in between shows
because Billie Holiday was homeless for
a lot of her childhood didn't and you
know had a rough childhood so I thought
this seems appropriate so I went in and
I had a check and it was in between
shows on a Saturday and there was two
sort of security cards there and they
said we don't have anybody here today is
the weekend who can take a check we
we're not allowed to do that we don't
we'll call around and see so just have a
seat so while I was waiting I saw a
young man come
and off the street with a trash bag and
he I looked about 15 maybe 16 and he
looked so world weary and exhausted and
frightened and defensive and these two
security guards had also been kind of
flirting with me and they were saying
you know you could write that check to
me and all this stuff and so I was you
know whatever and then they saw this kid
come in and they just left into action
like they were Batman and Robin and just
took this kid said hey you alright come
on in man we got you we got you okay
you're okay
what you need he knew sit down you want
something to drink you want something
eat we're gonna take care of you we got
you and my heart blew wide open and so I
got very involved with the Covenant
house and now I'm being an International
Board of Directors through the Covenant
House and in fact my my plan is to share
part of the award the McDermott award
with the government house to help
it's thank you it's because you know if
this Michelle Obama said you know once
you walk through that door of
opportunity you don't slam that door
behind you you reach back through and
help the next person wage backward and
help next person through and it's a it's
just important and I know it's a way
that will and I have been trying to
raise our kids and now we have our own
little 17 month old little monster that
we have now and if we can just keep her
out of jail she's great she's a wild
thing I don't know but we're teaching
them that they have to be good citizens
of the world and they have to get back
and so as we learn it we're trying to
teach it um and I just have to take them
over to say that also it is such a joy
to watch you and well together well as a
man and an artist I admire so so much
I've been so lucky to be able to work
with them
and to watch that you two guys are able
to make a life as actors and as a
marriage together has been just a
beautiful things but there's before we
take a few questions I just have to let
you know that I have promised Audra that
I'm not going to use this opportunity to
just get her to sign up for shows for me
if you would like to use this aside for
all everything we're going to do
together order what what are you what do
you want to do when you look ahead what
what are the one of the things you'd
still like to try to be scared by
everything seriously I mean I I I say it
all the time but it's sure I just want
to evolve as an artist as a person you
know as a you got to make good use of
the time we're given you know
and I I don't want to rest on my laurels
I don't want to be content with as I'm
grateful for the success that I've had
but I don't want to go okay that's it
I'm done I want to evolve I want to be a
better artist I want to be a better wife
I want to be a better mother because if
you're not evolving you know I want to
be a better citizen of the world I want
to I I mean maybe I have to maybe I'm
gonna run for office I don't know I mean
[Music]
I just want to do but I want to do
better I know that's grammatically not
correct sorry MIT I just wanted you know
I want to evolve um okay if you do that
you have a dispensation you don't have
to deny shows for me I will but other
than that you do it's um you know I
think anyway I'm not gonna sum up
because well instead we're gonna do is
we give the audience a chance to ask a
few questions I think we have
microphones and thanks so much so we'll
open it up
you know Audra there is one alternative
if in the evolution you might want to
come join our MIT faculty okay we can
talk to our president we'd be honored ah
so we have microphones and they're down
here and try to come up and maybe just
if you would if you have a question ask
just one so we give some time to others
I hope don't be shy either please anyone
this is really wild you're like Loki you
were like a huge vocal role model for me
and trying to like develop my own unique
voice and I really appreciate you know
gosh I'm tearing up okay but basically
this is kind of weird and like short for
the stairs at all anyways so like I
guess every role for an actor I don't
actually act but like I guess I feel
like every role is like another life
that you live and you can't really like
do that without having some growth and
change in yourself so my question is out
of all the roles you've ever played like
on stage or on screen which one has
changed you the most for better or for
worse yeah between you and Thalia man I
mean she has the most amazing questions
I'm telling you now you're getting me um
when it's changed me the most okay I'm
gonna answer that in a different way I'm
gonna tell you the one that was the
hardest to play okay it was the hardest
to find
and that was Ruth and Raisin in the Sun
and the reason why it was the hardest to
find because it was the closest to me on
paper and so I and I realized and I was
blocking because it was too close to me
she was a mom she she was you know an
exhausted wife or mom she you know
issues she you know
was dealing with a pregnancy also things
that I really understood and I was the
same age as her so I just I was blocked
by her and I was blocked and I once I
realized that I was blocked because it
was too close to me it was about
learning to like so maybe that role
changed me the most because it taught me
that I had to open up and go even deeper
and go to like what we were talking
about before like the third rail we're
talking about go to that third rail
which is a scary place to be but it's
where all the truth is you know and so
that's the one that taught me I think to
go to go super deep so that changed me
in a good way as an artist I think a
role that changed me in a bad way I
think my English teachers in 11th grade
would say it's when I played Ava Peron
in Evita at my dinner theater that I
grew up in because I guess I became a
bit of a [ __ ] at school because I was
playing and Evita at night and then
going to school me like what you want
one for me I'm not doing my homework
thank you very much
hi hi and she's gone thank you both for
being here
you're very very articulate and my
husband and I are who are New Yorkers
and partners for the public theater have
enjoyed seeing you at the Delacorte and
in other things but I can't resist
taking up the opening to say when are
you gonna come back to the public we'd
love to see you again
but corridor downtown oh man well i
[Music]
Delacorte we'd love to come back too I
mean anything in the public but the
Delacorte for sure there's something so
magical about playing the Delacorte and
being out in the open and doing
Shakespeare or whatever and you know and
then with the lovely baby raccoons
coming up on stage everyone during
Twelfth Night the baby raccoons came up
on stage and Anne Hathaway and I thought
that we were really killing the audience
they were just laughing like oh we're
nailing it come on Steven like we're
like we nailed that scene in the castles
like no the raccoons that come on mind
you yes any time that Oscar will have us
will and I will come thank you yeah
that's your membership dues for the year
um okay
take a deep breath you've been a hero of
mine um really ever since I heard your
voice I think it was on that there was a
Leonard Bernstein New York tribute album
man and I heard you sing a little bit of
love and I was more than a little bit in
love but and you were a hero of mine and
how you kind of code you the way you
combined your classical training with
musical theater and it was just sort of
a bolt hearing you talk about your
college experience and sort of
struggling to combine these in the kind
of the different camps that music
departments go into and I struggled with
that too and I ended up leaving a music
department but
I guess do you have I guess a would you
have any advice for college students
maybe struggling with that now or do you
get the sense that it's a little better
now that it's not kind of broken up in
camps in this way I mean you've well you
know I think I can't speak to every
college department I do know that there
have been a lot of changes implemented
at Julliard since the years that I've
been there and they allow for the
younger vocal students to have some
acting classes or they allow them to
sing a little bit of musical theater
they give them performance opportunities
now that we're not available to me and
my generation there and that's I think
made for a healthier sort of environment
a learning environment for these kids
and what my advice to the students has
always been listen and learn as much as
you can but trust your gut and and do
not try to sound like anybody else try
to sound like the best version of you
but do not try and imitate do not try
and sound like anybody else and that is
what will set you apart from everybody
else is that you have your own unique
sound and once I learned that that's
what sort of kind of sent me free and so
that's what I say to my students more
than anything thank you thank you
I twenty four years ago I saw you in
carousel and it was it's an indelible
memory and it was wonderful performance
and I still remember that so vividly my
gonna remember that till the day I die
oh really well thank you so much Lizzie
and a 110 degrees in the shade your very
high octane person and Lizzie is a plain
character what was your process in
deciding how to present this plainness
hmm when it wasn't inherit in the way
you self present well I think the
interesting thing about Lizzie is she's
not a plain character that's how though
that's how everybody in her life kept
describing herself describing her to her
and that's how she was sort of sort of
branded within the community you're
playing you know she talked a little too
much she was too smart she you know and
so for me it was instead I mean so I
just I mean in terms of what she looked
like okay so I didn't wear any makeup in
the show or anything like that but I
think Lizzie actually was a high octane
person with a lot of passion and a lot
of love to give and a lot of dreams and
aspirations that she kind of felt were
constantly being pushed down and so the
struggle for Lizzie is to truly believe
and that's what Starbuck gives her is
that she you know helps her to see that
she is beautiful she is she she is
deserving of love she she does have all
that within her so I didn't it was it's
I think it's quite actually the opposite
is that she was not that she was not
that and and the journey is discovering
that said she's not bad hi hi um so
you've worked both on stage and on
screen but you've also had your stage
work recorded as with Lady Day and on
HBO recording and I was wondering if you
could just speak a little bit to that
experience of taking what's somewhat
more ephemeral in nature as theatrical
performances are often described and how
it was like to do that for a single
recording
and what you think of kind of recording
theater in general although that's a
very touchy topic for a lot of people I
think it's very important for me maybe
it's just me being selfish I you know
there are performances that we'll never
have because they mean you know I would
have loved to have seen Merman in gypsy
can you imagine opening night of Hamlet
with Burbidge at the Globe Theatre
wouldn't if we enter for a tape so I
think I mean I love that Lincoln Center
Library Archives all the shows now is
that's very important that we have you
know that that history speaking to your
second or the first part of your
question we did Lady Day when we filmed
that we filmed it at a kind of defunct
cafe in New Orleans that we were able to
sort of turn into the the nightclub and
it was very difficult it was very
difficult we did it over three different
nights and we did have audience members
come in so we felt like was there there
people would have been in the I so
that's the realistic sort of portrayal
but it was very difficult because we
also had eleven cameras and that's a
very tiny space we had eleven cameras
and even like when she would go you know
off the stage and go to the bar and
stuff I was having to kind of walk by
and over camera dollies and stuff like
that
so it made for a sort of I had to sort
of I had to use different muscles and
for being completely honest
I don't I haven't seen it I honestly I
haven't and I think it's gonna be years
before I'm able to watch that
performance because it's no one wants
III I don't like watching myself on film
and I know what I went through and
trying to stay focused to get that
performance so it would be uncomfortable
for me to watch but it's it's very
tricky thing to do I don't think I
answered your question you absolutely
did thank you so much I mean one thing I
would say about that is I
lighted that the New York library for
performance exist and delighted that we
have theater theater on tape collection
and to me it is an academic research
tool yes I go up there to study stuff I
don't ever feel like I'm going up there
to have a complete experience of a work
of art I'm going up there it's a
historical record of a work of art that
isn't there anymore because I mean my
parochial view is that the theater is
supposed to vanish when you're that's
the whole truth of it just like we do so
but that doesn't mean I don't love
having it on tape thank you
you talked about thinking and
researching the roles but I'm curious
about practice and how you practice or
maybe rehearse in your field and and
what's different about that then when
you're you're standing and in the moment
and performing um do you mean in terms
of like you know rehearsal process yes
well I mean when you're working on any
show I mean you rehearse you know
usually six weeks six to eight weeks you
know and you know with like a Broadway
schedule you rehearse 10:00 to 6:00
every day six days a week for six to
eight weeks and then once you're up and
in previews before you officially open a
show you do the show at night and you
rehearse during the day as well and
aside from that you know a performer is
like an athlete you still have to you
still have to take your voice lessons
you have to keep yourself in tip-top
condition because it is our you know our
body is our instrument and so I you know
will and I both we still take voice
lessons and
you know and if like when I was doing
shuffle along I was having to learn how
to tap-dance or remember how to
tap-dance after 40 years of not doing it
I had to figure out how to do that again
so the training never stops you're
constantly in training I know you had a
second part the question what's it like
then once you stand on stage then you
here's the thing once you get up on
stage
you then have to throw it all out the
window that's the truth
you throw it all out the window and
you're forced to be in the moment and
and and just then it's I don't want to
say it's you're flying on blind faith
and luck but you do have to throw it all
out the window yeah you know and then
just go down to your gut do you want to
do it no but I think about it in an
athletic performance space yeah you
don't rehearse the marathon in the same
way that you run the marathon that's
true but you train for a marathon don't
you yeah absolutely thank you hi one of
my favorite plays was masterclass with
you oh I'm missing your signature
[Laughter]
I've been waiting two onions so Caldwell
signature and just wondered if you would
consider playing the part of Maria
Callas at this time or have you first of
all yes I will sign your poster I wasn't
there to sign it 22 years ago and
actually that question has been that has
been asked before if I would want to
play Maria Callas I am cute I think you
would should could it's an amazing role
it's hard because there's a part of me
that would absolutely love to do it but
there's a part of me that the
performance by so-called well who I
named my first child after is it's so
sacred to me that I I don't know that I
would want to touch it because it's so
sacred to me by my relationship to her
what she meant to me what that whole
experience meant to me and watching
every night her do it that I don't
there's a part of me that doesn't want
to be sacked there's a part of me that
feels that it might be sacrilegious to
play her just for it's it's my own
personal thing so I don't know but it's
an amazing role I'm begging because my I
will sign your poster after I promise
she is an amazing point thank you um so
last night you sing a song from the
perspective of a daughter whose mother
is a performer who's always away and you
mentioned kind of your goal to not be
that way so I'm just curious kind of a
personal question how do you and your
husband kind of make that not happen and
make sure that you know that that's not
how your children feel
kind of my god Mike is right there oh
it's it's like a Chinese jigsaw puzzle
we I don't know we just we like sit down
and have planning meetings you're going
to this soccer lesson and I'm going to
take this rehearsal and you have to work
this day and I like air traffic control
you know that's a better metaphor but
you know I mean we'll and I we don't not
like we go out and party a lot if we're
not working we're really with the kids
but we also make certain choices like we
don't we don't take you know we don't
really audition for like TV shows that
shoot in LA so that we can be home and
for a lot of actors that would minimize
a whole lot of work and you know years
ago it certainly did because there
wasn't a lot of film and television in
New York it was all LA and that's slowly
changing but yeah absolutely and yeah it
is it is a lot of planning and one foot
in front of you you know the other is
each day goes but literally when we're
not working we're with the kids and I
mean that's school year there's no
children present right now actually one
is here one did a tour of MIT today but
yeah so maybe I'll be giving the rest of
the award right back to MIT
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know what here's the thing you you
commit to finding a way to make it work
and you commit to being as good a parrot
as you possibly can and then you
prioritize and so it's like it's work or
they're kids and if they have other
plans then we'll sneak away but other
than that it's work or their kids yeah
yeah thank you yeah you can do it you
can do it but take your time
[Applause]
hello how are you it's good to see you
I'm wondering you received this phone
call from the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology to be told that you're going
to get a McDermott award and did you
think they got the wrong number first of
all I'm just wondering if you could tell
us what did what surprised you about the
residency what surprised you about the
students faculty what was your
experience um you know you hear MIT and
if you're as intelligent as I am which
is you know not much intelligence but I
I I think so I you know I had a sort of
preconceived sort of idea a notion of
what the students would be like I and I
was telling Thalia this student that I
had the interview with us telling her
this earlier you know I had you know
this sort of you know they're you know
they're all got their heads in books or
they're you know working on you know
they're blowing up things in a science
lab or they're you know what there's
what what could I possibly teach them
and are they even going to be interested
and what I discovered is these kids are
not only they do not have their heads in
books that though that that's a lot of
it cuz they have to but they are wide
eyed and curious and precocious and and
and and they seem to be full of joy
and and what I got a sense for all that
was like does this make sense
I this is what I feel when I think about
these kids I see them reaching and arms
open and wanting to discover and so for
me coming in to spend time with them and
and talk to them and and the few sort of
master classes that I gave or helping
they were just sponges full of joy and
Wonder and I always felt very hopeful
when I left you know that if these kids
want to not only you know figure out how
to get us to Saturn you know cure cancer
and sing an aria all in one day if they
want to do it they can they can and yeah
I was very inspired the faculty is that
they give them the support and the space
they give them the support and the space
and what I didn't expect but what I was
thrilled to see is there's a warmth that
comes from the faculty the faculty that
I've spent there's warmth that that they
there's a warmth and a genuine caring
that they have for their students and
that that filled me with a great deal of
hope let me especially like watching the
way Laura works with her kids you could
tell she loves each and every one of
those kids so much and is there for them
and and support so especially as a mom
we're getting ready you know two of our
oldest are going off to college in a
year to know that you could send your
kids to you know a place like this or
wherever you go and there's going to be
the support warmth and love as well as
the knowledge that they need I was
inspired I I'm I'm a convert if I can
just add I came here last night I was in
Vancouver
speaking at the TED conference and I'm
surprised anybody's here because it felt
like the entire MIT faculty was
presenting but the the kind of genius
technological genius that I was hearing
over the
few days in Vancouver the idea that that
can be coupled with an understanding of
the importance of art and the importance
of what culture means not just in
general but particulars research
particularly the idea of science and
advancement
it's as many some of you are old enough
to remember CPS knows the two cultures
the more that we can get the culture and
the science the technology and the art
to speak to each other the more likely
we are to have a world that we want to
live in
hi I loved in the video real hearing you
talk about having a riff there's
something if there's a role or something
that you're scared of that you have to
do it because it'll make you better even
if it's not successful so I was I was
thinking I was wondering if there was a
time that came to mind that you can
think of when you were working through
that where you were doing something you
were scared of and it maybe wasn't as
successful as you would have hoped and
do you have anything what would you say
to somebody who might be in that space
right now I would say to you wait come
here go away I would say don't don't
don't be afraid of the failure the
failure is as part of the learning
experience and I've failed on a daily
basis on a daily basis you fail if you
succeeded everything you won't ever grow
because you won't ever learn yeah I
firmly believe that and you know let me
give be personal let me give you an
example as recently as yesterday I was
scared to death to do Laura's piece at
the concert last night because we had
only rehearsed it once and I felt like I
don't want to let Laura down and not do
it here this is her home this is where
she's teaching this is where the kids
are and this is where I learned the
piece but I'm not ready and I'm scared
and so the at the point in the concert
when it was time to do it I turned to
the pianist and he said do you want to
do it and I said I've got a mess up and
he was like okay and he started to turn
the page to the next song and then I
thought you're scared you need to do it
and I turned back to my said let's do it
so last night you fail on a Dan I didn't
get it all right I mean some of the kids
I know what I messed up on the
out of the lyrics but oh whoa sorry
Laura I'll get it right by May first I
will but it doesn't matter but I'm glad
I did it and I learned and I fell a
little bit on my face but in the end and
you know what and so instead of just
hiding all that from the audience I told
the honest like this I rehearsed this
once I need to do it let's see what
happens and I said to the kids if I mess
up shout out the words to me we'll get
through it
so fail everyday you'll learn something
[Laughter]
hey um first of all I want to say thank
you because when I was in seventh grade
I saw you in porgy and bess in New York
and that's probably 90% of the reason
why I started singing oh my god so and
then my question is as a singer who
mainly has classical training I was
wondering if you had any tips for
expanding to other vocal genres without
losing touch with my own voice sing what
seeing what you love does that make
sense
sing what you love I mean even if it's I
mean sometimes at home I'm singing an
earth one in fire I love Earth Wind and
Fire you know and so I'm it's coming
from a place of joy in my heart and that
means it's something that wants to I
mean you've you fancy yourself a singer
absolutely right it's a part of who you
are so if you sing from a place of love
and a sing from a place of something
that you want that gives you joy just do
it the only thing I would say is May as
long as you're singing with your voice
that's all that matters don't don't try
and be anybody else
I don't sing Earth Wind and Fire like
philipbaillie you know I wish I could
sing like Philip Bailey but I don't I
mean we sing the same octave because
he's saying very much
but I sing like me so I'm bringing my
own interpretation to it but I love it
and I want to sing it and I have
something to say about that music about
you know September's song or you know
got to get you into my life whatever it
doesn't matter that I'm singing it with
with my voice so stick with your own
voice but sing what you want
thank you she was that you were at the
lunch too via the yes yes I its you're
backlit now I see your face hi
so did we head like flan or something at
the when we had the lunch the creme
brulee that's right yes I was wondering
so like your machine who did research
like your votes and stuff and so a lot
of Mike Havel of historical context and
all that I don't really like so our
school my high school it did ragtime my
freshman yeah it's like that's why it
was so soundcheck that was my first deal
what about you and it was amazing but so
I was wondering like so when you have
like I'll do a research and then you
have all the context in the background
so how do you balance that like that
that information with their own
interpretations and like and we're
performing at Moe's how do i balance all
the information from all the research
that I've done with my own
interpretation oh yeah I like how how
you like insert herself into the into
the role the research is there to
support you you know I mean but in the
end the role has to be filtered through
you so you take that research and and
it's there and it's it's it's there to
support you as you then plug it into
your own soul and then in the end you
can't take all those books and
recordings and everything out on the
stage with you you go alright I'm gonna
play Billie Holiday but let me show you
how you know I swear this is right check
this out because in the end that's why
I'm saying when I said to him you got to
throw it all out the window it's there
to support you you know in that phase of
it but then at the end you throw it out
the window and then it's how you it then
filters through yourself so in the end
it does become up to you and it becomes
a part of who you are I mean I would
imagine I don't know about the sciences
that I would imagine in some way you
know you can look at all the research
but then you have to come to your own
conclusion about what all the research
has shown you right it has to be your
conclusion in the end so I think maybe
it's the same
so Audra first congratulations on the
2018 Eugene McDermott award in the arts
at MIT
you're spectacular you've honored us and
you brought Oscar with you to double
honors and the two of you are phenomenal
together and you could see this audience
just deeply appreciates what you've done
for us on this occasion please stay
close to us
you